scp-682 versus scp-061  could a mind-controlling music program  finally be the key to destroying the  infamous hard-to-destroy reptile 682  enter the relaxed state typical of  people undergoing 0-6-1 hypnosis at  first as the foundation gave a number of  menial orders such as rolling over 682  clearly tried to resist even entering a  violent seizure when ordered to stand up  it suddenly became immune to 061's  powers carrying out a violent assault on  the staff and breaching containment it  appeared to somehow integrate the  abilities of 061 into its own biology  releasing a screech that stunned  everybody nearby and allowing it to  devour several people before it was  recontained